(rock music)
- So, yeah, hey, my
name is Mark Normand,
from New Orleans, Lousiana.
Who dat?
And I started comedy
there at a real dive bar
I got hammered, I had a yeast
infection and I got hammered
and I talked about it
and it went pretty well.
And then I moved to New York.
A couple of friends
of mine moved up.
I said, "I'm going with ya."
Moved to Crown
Heights, Brooklyn, got
mugged three times,
landlord died of AIDS, and
the first night I was there,
there was a pigeon
in my apartment.
I like a good Netflix document.
Occasionally, I'll
hit a treadmill.
I like to put on a
little Van Morrison
and look at people's
Facebook photos.
You ever do that, just
stay up late at night,
looking for that bikini
shot of a girl, you know?
Alright, finally, I've
got that Florida trip.
There we go.
Alright.
Have a glass of
red wine, you know.
Good times.
(laughs)
You guys do that, right?
Today I spent the
whole day on Facebook?
(crowd laughs)
Let me ask you guys this.
You guys ever Google something
and you notice on your
Facebook wall, there's an ad
for the thing you Googled?
Well, what the hell is that?
I was on my Facebook wall today,
there was an ad
for sexy cougars.
(crowd laughs)
I was like, hey Google,
that was between us.
(crowd laughs)
First of all, I've had
every bad job in the book.
Busboy, I was a furniture mover,
I was an office temp, janitor.
Janitor, worst job ever.
Got fired because I was
mopping - true story - mopping,
a guy slipped, he yelled at
me for not putting a sign out
but I was mopping
in front of him.
I'm mopping in front of you,
what, what, what's the sign?
What's the point?
I am the sign?
Quit every other job I had.
I would, I'm, I'm such a
pussy that I can't quit stuff,
so I would just tell, I'd
be like, my grandmother,
she won't leave my
apartment, I've got to go,
you know, fight her.
I can't come back into work.
I'm running a cock fight,
I can't come back in.
Like, I'd just make up all
these crazy excuses, you know.
(laughs)
I used to live with an
Asian guy, a Chinese guy,
and one time, we were
walking around in Brooklyn,
somebody called
him a "Chinaman."
He was devastated.
But can we all agree
that's definitely
the gentlest of
the racial slurs.
(crowd laughs)
And he was saying, no
it's horrible racial slur,
and I was like, he's
from China, he's a man.
That's not so bad.
To me, I think the names of
Chinese restaurants sound
a lot more like racial slurs.
I remember seeing a
Chinese restaurant,
it was called like, Panda
Express, and I was, like,
that sounds like a racial slur.
You know who can't drive?
Those god-damn Panda Kings.
(crowd laughs)
I'll tell you that
right now, yeah.
And listen to this, one
of those Golden Noodles
just moved into my
apartment building.
(crowd laughs)
Those guys really burn me
up, those Lucky Dragon.
(crowd laughs)
(rock music)